[Music]
how about a family who is doing more
than okay the Kardashians they start
filming the next season of their reality
series tomorrow and they just signed a
multi-year deal for additional seasons
reportedly for a cool 150 million
dollars and only our Cameron Mathison is
keep it up with momager Kris Jenner he
joins us now from New York with more hi
cam yeah dance the empire that chris has
helped create is reaching billion-dollar
status not to mention the fact that
she's expecting some new additions to
the Jenner Kardashian clan but the
biggest change for Kris right now might
be for new Blonde Ambition I was
expecting to see you with some blond
hair today I want you know is gonna dye
my hair blonde and so you know Kim's
like let's try a wig and so we did so
and they took a picture but after the
martini I forgot and then she posted it
up like as the woman behind the
Kardashian Empire Kris says the key to
her success is keeping it all in the
family
between the television shows and
cosmetic lines and and just about
everything and how do you how do you
just keep it all straight well it's not
a lot of sleep I'm really lucky because
I have all the girls and Rob who have
the best work ethic in the world so it
takes a village at 61 Chris's grandma
has six grandkids with more on the way
Kim and Kanye are expecting baby number
three via surrogate and our sources tell
us Khloe and Kylie are pregnant to 20
year old Kylie's makeup line is poised
to become a billion-dollar business soon
how do you think major life changes for
such a young woman will impact her
business world in her business empire
she's really I think equipped to handle
whatever comes her way I'm so proud of
that kid we caught up with Chris at the
WWD apparel and CEO summit where she
spoke today but even though this family
works hard they also play hard so prank
calls are something of a kart for the
Kardashians
is there any shot filly that I can
convince you to do a little prank call
like with the truth with one of your
kids right now
we could try Chloe hi hi boo listen I
have a really quick question they asked
me to do playboy and play
naked you're gonna be naked so is that a
no listen it's your life I support you
you support us there's just a real thing
though Chloe I love you so much this is
a prank call and I'm on Entertainment
Tonight and this is wild that you were
so nice to me this come on how good was
that now you should know I gave Chris no
warning for that prank crazy busy day
for her middle of the interview I just
dropped the idea she grabs her phone and
she goes for
[Music]
you